.
AvAvec mon Geneviève Guilbault.
BoBonsoir.
- - Bonsoir Monsieur Roy.
- - On va parler de ce bracelet,
unune nouvelle qui peut de façon
trtrès pratique aider les femmes
ququi se sentent menacées par ds
coconjoints violents ou des ex
coconjoint violent. D'abord, en
cocommentaire. Ça commence à fae
papas mal de vidéos. Est-ce que
vovous vous dîtes que je devrais
coconfier un autre corps, que ce
sosoit un autre, une enquête
cocomplète sur les services de
popolice de la ville de Québec?
- - Pour l'instant, j'ai vu la
trtroisième vidéo en milieu
d'd'après-midi entre deux
rerencontres. Effectivement, on
esest en communication avec la
viville de Québec pour avoir pls
d'd'informations. Mais vous savz
quque j'aiai déjà confié, deux
auautres vidéos, sur deux autres
ininterventions de la fin de
sesemaine dernière. On ne sait s
exexactement quand se dérouler a
trtroisième. Pour les deux
prpremières cette fin de semain.
J'J'ai mandaté le commissaire àa
dédéontologie policière pour fae
dedes enquêtes en plus des deux
enenquêtes qui ont été demandées
ininternes par les services de
popolice de la ville de QuébecÀA
cecette question, est-ce que le
BEBEI, pourquoi pas le BEI? Je
coconfie l'enquête au BEI il
auaurait pour mandat d'enquêter
sosous l'angle d'infraction ou
d'd'allégation potentiellement
crcriminelle. Est-ce qu'il y a u
ququelque chose criminelle? Si
ououi, est-ce que c'est assez pr
..... c'est très circonscrit. Il
pepeut y avoir bien des criminee
mamais peut-être des enjeux
dédéontologiques. Le rapport du
BEBEI serait confidentiel. Avece
cocommissaire à la déontologie
popolicière, on nous demandait
enenquête indépendante. Il être
inindépendant et la tous les
popouvoirs ne commissaire pas li
auaussi pourrait encore de
reredécouvrir peut-être des
éléléments potentiellement
crcriminels, il pourra s'adressr
àà un corps de police pour un
enenquête criminel et exhaustif.
IlIl peut aussi aborder l'angle
dédéontologie. Est-ce que le coe
dede déontologie a été respecté?
EtEt l'information qui nous
trtransmettra, je m'engage à
rerendre tout cela public. Deux
popoints de vue de transparencet
d'd'enquête complète, c'est
bebeaucoup plus intéressant de
mamandater le commissaire
- - Comment vous avez réagi? Vos
avavez regarde la 3 Zambito
rarapidement. Il y a quand même
dadans cette vidéo, des choses
trtroublantes. La politique
s's'adresse de façon très
agagressive à l'homme en questi.
LeLe pouce sur la voiture...
c'c'est troublant.
- - S'ajoutant plutôt aux deux
auautres. Il y a une séquence de
trtrois. On n'a pas encore danse
cocontexte et je voyais un extrt
dudu bar de Québec qui dit, et e
lele dis depuis quelques jours n
nene sait pas ce qui est arrivé
avavant et après. On a seulement
lala partie fragmentaire de ce i
esest sur la vidéo. D'où
l'l'importance avant les enquêts
dede l'information plus complèt.
OrOr ces enquêtes internes et
susurtout cette information à
sasavoir d'où, à quel moment ele
dédéroulait l'intervention qui
sosont ces policiers? La policee
QuQuébec devrait être en mesure
d'd'avoir cette information, de
cocommuniquer ses il y a lieu
enentourant cette affaire. Il ne
fafaut pas aussi perdre de vue e
fafait que ce service de police
mumunicipale. L'employeur de ces
popoliciers et les services de
popolice. La direction de la vie
dede Québec. C'est à eux aussi à
prprendre en charge toute la
ququestion des bonnes pratiques,
dede la gestion s'arrache etc. e
nene vais pas me substituer. Jea
lalaisse par ces communications.
J'J'ai pris ma responsabilité de
miministre de la sécurité publie
enen mandatant le commissaire àa
dédéontologie qui pourra nous
fafaire rapport. Il y a des
mamanquements, il y a une instae
apappelle le comité de la
dédéontologie policière devant
lelesquels peuvent comparaître s
popoliciers et avoir des
sasanctions. Si il y a lieu. On
veverra.
- - On va regarder ça.
LeLe bracelet : vous avez en
coconférence de presse qu'on n'a
papas le luxe d'attendre. On n'a
papas... elle aurait pu prendre
101000 avant qu'on développe ce
gegenre de technologie. Ça exise
papas d'enquête sur la planète.l
y y a cinq pays je crois qui en
onont. C'est un bracelet, il fat
l'l'expliquer. C'est électroniqe
mamais c'est pas pour garder
ququelqu'un la maison. C'est por
emempêcher que quelques secondes
chchez son ex conjoint.
- - Oui et c'est différent du
brbracelet électronique. On les
memet sur un contrevenant, par
exexemple terroriste convie
susurveiller. On parle d'un
brbracelet anti rapprochement. l
y y a deux parties à ce
didispositif. Il y a une partie
ququ'on installe son auteur de
viviolences conjugales, qui gare
enen permanence qui n'avait pas
enenlevé. On peut le suivre en
pepermanence à distance. Et une
auautre partie que c'est la
vivictime qui a l'autre partie.
C'C'est une boîte de peut traînr
avavec elle. Elle permet qu'il a
totoujours un lien, une
trtraçabilité entre une
gégéolocalisation réciproque ene
leles deux parties. Donc c'est e
cocontrevenant s'approche dans e
zozone qui luiui est interdite,
auauprès de la victime, il y a e
alalerte qui est donnée aux
popoliciers et les policiers
pepeuvent te rendre pour sécurir
lala victime pourraient assurer
quque le contrevenant ne fait ps
l'l'approcher. Dans un deuxième
tetemps, localisé le contrevenat
enen question parce que en
prprécondition. C'est très conct
etet c'est très technique. C'est
trtrès prometteur, surtout ça pt
raramener la paix d'esprit aux
fefemmes qui sont prises dans
l'l'enfer de la violence
coconjugale. Ces auteurs de
viviolences lors des robes, leur
enenlève la paix d'esprit et
l'l'autonomie sur la propre vie.
ExExport avec ça de la redonner
cecette autonomie et cette
cacapacité de vivre un tant soit
pepeu normalement.
- - On pensa qu'il est très
prprécisément? Des gens qui ont
étété... faut-il avoir été
cocondamné pour violences
coconjugales? Ou on peut être en
atattente de procès et la loi pt
nonous obliger à le porter?
- - Les deux sont possibleles.
AuAu tout début d'un processus
jujudiciaire quand un homme est
acaccusé par exemple de voies de
fafait, ou d'une offensive en
viviolences conjugales, il
cocomparaît devant le juge il dt
dédécider, le juge, s'il va être
dédétenu ou pas. Cela remet en
liliberté il va pouvoir imposere
brbracelet. La victime à cette
sésécurité d'esprit dont je vous
paparlais parce que s'il est res
enen liberté sans bracelet, les
fefemmes disent que même s'il na
papas le droit de m'approcher ji
totoujours pas qu'elle vienne cz
momoi quand même.
- - Mais ce n'est pas condamné.l
enen attente de procès.
HaHabituellement, on lui donne n
orordre pas approcher de la fem,
mamais souvent, et ne respecte s
cecet ordre. On va faire en sore
ququ'il respecte cet ordre.
- - Oui, et d'amener la paix
d'd'esprit. Ce sera la distractn
dedes juges. Ils auront le pouvr
dede l'imposer. Ils décideront.
C'C'est à l'écart du gouvernemet
etet tout ça. Je vais pas me
susubstituer à éventuelle décisn
d'd'un juge. Mais ça va être
popossible aussi de l'imposer pr
dedes éventuelles fins de
sesentence. Un jour les gens sot
dedes prisons. Les femmes sont
ststressées aussi. Le juge poura
didire à la fin de la sentence,à
lala fin de la peine de détenti,
ilil va porter la bracelet pour8
momois 24 mois.
- - On pense que combien d'homms
vovont porter ça?
- - C'est difficile à évaluer pr
lele moment. On a un bassin
popotentiel approximatif d'envin
232300 hommes qui sont condamnés
popour des infractions de nature
dede violences conjugales
anannuellement. A ca, il faut
enenlever les personnes qui ont
dedes de santé mentale par exeme
auau refus de la victime. Elle
popourra être installée avec le
coconsentement de la victime. Si
lala victime n'avait pas traînéa
G G auxquels on ne prend pas les
paparpaings on envisage 500
brbracelets d'ici deux ans. On a
l'l'implanter, le premier
brbracelet, je m'attends à ce
ququ'on efface en février ou ma.
UnUne femme et un homme. La
prpremière femme qui pourra vive
l'l'expérience de la paix
d'd'esprit. Début 2022 et fin 23
cece sera implanté partout Québ.
OnOn envisage pour l'instant 500
brbracelets et évidemment au fur
etet à mesure avoir si elle ente
enen plus. Pour l'instant, c'est
lele rodage et l'apprivoisement,
etet on l'espère le succès de
cecette mesure.
- - C'est un rodage mais est-ce
quque c'est un projet pilote? E-
cece que vous pourriez dire qu'n
aiaime pas ça ou ce qu'on y va?
- - En ce moment c'est ce qu'ony
vava. On implante progressivemet
lele bracelet au Québec sur deux
anans. On est en décembre 2021,
dédécembre 2023 elle va être
didisponible partout. On commene
unun projet dans la vie de Québc
paparce que les conditions
gagagnantes réussies. La premièe
fofois, c'est ce que ça va être
unune vraie expérience. Les gens
dedevront s'habituer. Ont embaué
dedes ressources pour que tout e
momonde s'habituait. Mais oui, e
vovois très bien conserver ça.
- - Les centres qui aident les
fefemmes en détresse ont applaui
lala mesure. On dit...
cocomme je vous disais, on peut
sosouligner que ça été fait quad
mmême rapidement. On n'en parle
dedepuis un certain nombre
d'd'années, mais là,
vovous aidiez devant le nombre e
féféminicide, je répète que je s
auau tout début, on n'a pas le
luluxe d'attendre. Vous allez
chchanger de l'argent et ça y e.
- - J'ai déjà annoncé 223 millis
anantérieurement. J'avais annoné
enen décembre dernier qu'on
fafaisait l'étude de faisabilité
d'd'implantation du bracelet. Il
fafallait quand même voir ce qui
sese faisait ailleurs. Six Pilon
enen ce moment. Comment est-ce
ququ'on prenne implanter ici? Ji
rereçu mon rapport final le 31
ococtobre et on est le 1er
dédécembre. On annonce qu'on
imimplante progressivement. On
cocommence très bientôt.
J'J'ai fait ça rapidement parce
quque 18 féminicide, c'est asse.
SiSi on peut en empêcher ne
seserait-ce qu'un seul avec sa
brbracelet et surtout cet appel
esesprit, elle n'a pas de prix.
CoCompare nos femmes, ça en fait
paparce qu'elles vivent.
CÇa peut apporter l'appel esprit
ilillimité les futures actions
viviolentes, je pense que